7 a.m september 11 1973. something
strange is happening in the south
american country of chile the
democratically elected president
salvatore allende has just been informed
that there was a plot to kill him and
overthrow chile allende and his
bodyguards rushed to the presidential
palace never dreaming that in just a few
hours most of them would be dead
8 am tv and radio channels across the
country are taken down people start
panicking
8 30 am the military stores the
presidential palace but they're not
there to save the president or bring
peace they're storming the palace to
bring allende to his knees a bloody
battle follows most of salvador
allende's bodyguards are killed the army
demands ayende step down but he refuses
their reply more shooting
suddenly explosions shake the building
bomber playing straight past the
presidential palace as it goes up in
flames salvador allende must have
realized the end was nearer his
bodyguards are dead the enemy has him
surrounded it was only a matter of time
before they finally capture him or worse
so salvador takes his own life
at 2 30 pm on september 11 1973 chile's
history is forever changed a new
president takes allende's place and
darkness descends over chile
the 1973 chilean coup was one of the
most unexpected events in latin american
history but the story behind it is even
more shocking it was the only confirmed
time in history where a u.s president
explicitly ordered the overthrow of a
democratically elected government
america was supposed to uphold democracy
it was supposed to protect democratic
governments but here was directly
responsible for the death of a
democratic president
the chilean coup of 1973 is a lesson a
lesson about the cia powerful american
conglomerates that rival the power of
nation states and why you don't get in
their way
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime with my team and this is how the
uso chile
no matter what your views are on
communism you have to admit they have
pretty great branding aesthetically
pleasing art that's visceral memorable
it shot fear into his enemies and
camaraderie into his supporters that is
the power of branding and the easiest
way to design a great brand canva pro
today's video sponsor canva pro is the
easiest way to create instagram stories
instagram posts logos youtube thumbnails
youtube channel art presentations even
full blown videos it's honestly pretty
insane how much you can do there's a
reason why canva has over 60 million
monthly users it's got thousands of easy
to use customizable templates made by
professional designers stuff that
actually looks shockingly good it's
super intuitive to use you can work on
mobile or desktop canva basically makes
it impossible for you to design
something ugly and canva even has a
completely free version as well but you
really want to get canva pro or else
you're going to miss out on a ton of
great tools that are going to save you
hours of tedious work there's the brand
kit tool where you can preset your
brand's fonts colors and logo so you
always have a unified look across all
your designs there's the magic resizer
which allows you to resize designs for
all other platforms in a few clicks they
also have their instant one-click
background remover removing a background
is usually a frustrating process that
you have to manually do in a more
advanced editing tool but with this is
just one click but my favorite feature
of canva pro by far is their content
planner which allows you to schedule
your canva creations to go live on
almost all major social media platforms
social media schedulers usually cost
around the same amount as canva pro
anyways so this feature alone pays for
itself
one thing i love using canva for is
doing simple edits on my phone for
instagram pictures like when i need to
sensor out sensitive stuff before
posting a photo if you want to start
making more professional content in less
time you can get a free 45-day extended
trial by going to canva dot message jake
tran after that you can unlock
everything canva pro has to offer for up
to five people for just 12.95 per month
that's canva dot message tran for a
45-day free trial now back to the
documentary
[Music]
let's say you lived in a poor country in
south america in the 60s and 70s most of
the big businesses in your country are
run by foreigners the locals were
treated only slightly better than slaves
if you were in this environment wouldn't
you want to see change wouldn't you want
to see all those big businesses return
to the people well that's exactly what
communism promised you see all the oil
companies mining companies and
businesses owned by america the ones
that exploit our natural resources take
away our wealth and leave us with scraps
we'll give them back to the people that
was the rhetoric behind latin america
communism and it spread like a wildfire
and this south american communist
movement all started with fidel castro
in cuba and that's who america pointed
the finger at for decades every
government overthrown every coup
supported every politician assassinated
in latin america was somehow castro's
fault and chile was no different around
the same time the soviet union was
desperately looking for an ally near
america somewhere they could store their
missiles and station their troops in
case nuclear war broke out so when
salvador allende a socialist and marxist
decided to run for president in the 60s
something had to be done if chile turned
communist the soviet union could close
in on america even more to add to that
threat
allende was promising big things like
nationalizing chile's very profitable
copper mining industry basically
nationalizing an industry means taking
it out of private control and placing it
under the government or local control
and who owned chile's copper industry it
wasn't chilean companies but american
conglomerates of course
so
[Music]
it's hard to put into words how big and
powerful these american copper
conglomerates were one of them was
anaconda copper and for much of the 20th
century they were one of the biggest
mining companies in the world the other
was kennicott utah copper who controlled
the el tiente mine in chile the world's
largest underground copper mine
these mines were massive operations and
since they were located in the middle of
nowhere these american companies built
literal self-sustaining cities around
the mines to house their workers they
had their own water and electrical
plants their own schools stores railways
and even their own police forces in some
cases these city-states weren't run by
the chilean government but by american
corporations that's how profitable the
business was where it made sense for you
to build your own cities and this
profitable business was under threat of
being taken away from them by this new
communist presidential candidate
salvador allende was not only in the
crosshairs of the us government but also
these corporations that rival the power
of nation states and they were not going
to let allende win so when allende ran
for president in 1964 the cia secretly
spent three million dollars on making
sure his opponent won instead of allende
winning eduardo free won the election
so if you've ever wondered how much it
cost to buy a government 28 million
dollars is the answer in today's money
free was friendly towards america and
allowed chilean soldiers to be trained
at u.s bases the u.s even gave chile 163
million dollars in military aid while
free was president
for a while america thought they had
avoided the worst but they had only
underestimated allende's resolve to win
because just five years later salvador
allende announced his plans to run for
president again and the fight was on
[Applause]
[Music]
allende's second run at becoming
president started out a lot like the
first richard nixon was president of
america with henry kissinger as his
secretary of state together they made
the most anti-communist duo in u.s
presidential history and they were not
about to let a marxist get the better of
them so they went back to their old
tricks the us government along with the
american businesses in chile started
funneling monday to allende's opposition
hoping the other candidates campaigns
would leave allende in the dust allende
was also now promising to nationalize
the telecoms industry so itt an
international telecoms company in chile
was at the front of the push to keep
allende out of power the only problem
was allende knew the game the americans
were playing now and no matter how much
money america poured into the other
side's pockets allende was just going to
keep getting more and more popular
chile's election day arrives the results
rademiro tomic opponent number one comes
in with 28.1 percent of the vote
jorge alessandri opponent 2 got 35.3
percent and salvador allende he beat
jorge by just 1.6
for a total of 36.6 of the vote
according to chile's law if none of the
candidates got the majority of votes
meaning 50.1 percent congress has to
pick a winner traditionally congress
would choose the guy with the most votes
out of all the candidates
but not if america had something to do
about it
this is an important document this is
the only extant document the only
declassified document we have
of the president of the united states of
america ordering the overthrow of a
democratically elected government this
document is dated september fifteenth
nineteen seventy allende is not due to
be inaugurated for another six weeks
until november third
nineteen seventy he has not yet assumed
the presidency he has yet to implement
as president of chile a single
a single policy detrimental to u.s
interests
and yet
nixon had decided
as cia director helms told his staff the
next day that allende was and i quote
unacceptable to the united states
and had ordered the cia to foment
this coup
within days of the election nixon
deploys a team on the chilean congress
trying to pressure them into choosing
anyone else at the same time the cia
starts putting out feelers officers get
in touch with their sources and start
asking vague questions like if there was
a coup would the military support it
nothing is really in the works yet
they're just trying to get the lay of
the land unfortunately they didn't get
the answer they're looking for the head
of the army renee schneider sent a
message back he doesn't care who's in
charge his job is to protect chile not
get involved in politics
translation the army will defend
whichever president congress chooses
obviously this renee guy has got to go
so they came up with a plan to kidnap
the head of the army forced him to step
down and replace him with a pro-us
general luckily for the cia the kidnap
plan went sideways and the head of the
army ended up dead anyways back in the
chilean congress america hadn't been
able to change chile's congress's mind
on who to choose so on november 3rd 1970
salvador allende was sworn in as the
president of chile making him the first
marxist to be elected president in a
liberal democracy in latin america this
also meant that his fate was sealed the
cia had already received their orders no
expense spared no risk too great
10 million at their disposal just to
overthrow salvador allende
[Music]
salvador allende wasted no time becoming
america's biggest headache under allende
all of the us's biggest fears became
reality allende nationalized the copper
mining industry he nationalized the
telecoms industry and all the land owned
by americans suddenly got taken back to
be redistributed among the poor the
foreign conglomerates just lost billions
in the blink of an eye it was a
communist nightmare and the cia was
desperately looking for a way to get
allende out unfortunately for allende
all these economic changes were putting
a lot of pressure on a country that
wasn't exactly rich to begin with and
that's where america saw their chance go
after chile's weaknesses make life
miserable for the chilean people make
sure the finger is pointed at this new
communist leader and they'll overthrow
the government for you
and
make chile's economy scream those were
the orders given by henry kissinger to
the cia
in order for a coup to happen while it
not looking like the coup was
orchestrated by america we would need
the people of chile to suffer so much
that they would be the ones who
overthrew allende then america could sit
back and say we had nothing to do with
this
so america withdrew all its aid to chile
it blocked most forms of trade every
time chile applied for a loan from
banking institutions like the
international monetary fund and world
bank both of which america had the most
votes in america would vote against them
and they would be denied
in the first two years of allende's rule
inflation skyrocketed life became
unaffordable no matter how hard allende
tried to subsidize stuff and live by his
socialist ideals with people angry over
the economy and desperate for some sort
of outside help it was the perfect time
for the cia to implement phase two of
their plan encouraging chaos
you have asked us to provoke chaos in
chile we provide you with a formula for
chaos which is unlikely to be bloodless
that's what a cia agent in chile wrote
to headquarters so cia agents got to
work making chaos a reality they
infiltrated unions they organized
strikes they paid for anti-allende
propaganda to be spread all over the
country chile descended into darkness
while allende desperately tried to keep
control of a country at war with itself
the people didn't have enough food to
eat they didn't have enough money for
electricity and gas chile had become
ripe for a coup now all the cia needed
was someone to lead it
june 1973
a small group of right-wing chilean
activists attempted a coup ultimately
they failed but it's enough for allende
to get nervous so he turns to the army
for protection he hopes that by keeping
the army on his side he can keep peace
in chile the only problem is the army
allende hopes will keep him safe would
be the first to betray him august 1973
president allende appoints augusto
pinochet as head of the army he trusts
pinochet with his life but that's where
he makes his mistake because as it turns
out pinochet isn't as interested in
keeping allende safe as he isn't taking
power for himself the one man allende
trusts turns out to be the one planning
his demise
with the army on his side general
pinochet chooses september 11th 1973 as
the downfall of chile
[Music]
[Music]
september 11th 1973
the army surrounds the presidential
palace where salvador allende is hiding
on pinochet's orders bomber planes
attacked the building sending explosions
ringing through the city allende must
have known it was the end that's when
allende pulls out an ak-47 gifted to him
from his friend fidel castro and shoots
himself
[Music]
india
[Music]
the cia will never admit their
involvement but the trail is clear
without them causing chaos in chile
without their support for pinochet the
coup would never have happened
america had been directly responsible
for the overthrow of a democratic
government in the end they had gotten
what they wanted
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
but they hadn't once stopped to think
what would happen afterwards
in the days following the coup
soldiers rounded up thousands of
chileans workers students politicians
and artists were arrested and imprisoned
the folk singer viktor hara was captured
and tortured his hands were broken
later he was killed
many were taken to the national soccer
stadium and held prisoner there
little did they know what general
pinochet had in store for chile
[Music]
after allende's death the chilean
government dissolved and the military
takes control of the country unlike with
allende the us almost immediately
recognizes this new government and
offers support
general pinochet becomes chile's new
president his first orders hunt down
anyone who supported allende and get rid
of them
in the first three weeks after the coup
more than 1 000 civilians were executed
and nearly 14 000 rounded up and
tortured instead of reestablishing a
stable government in chile general
pinochet becomes a dictator and controls
chile for the next 17 years
during his first three years in power
the government arrests and likely
tortures over 130 000 people and a hit
squad known as the caravan of death
executes at least 72 political prisoners
pinochet is everything america should be
fighting against a human rights abuser
an autocrat and a dictator but when
asked about the coup in chile henry
kissinger still insists that even though
pinochet is doing some questionable
stuff at least he wasn't a communist
the message was clear as long as you
don't get in the way of american
interests anything goes
this was a super dramatic and
interesting story that our team got to
cover so let me know what you guys
thought about it in the comments below
and if you're new here we run one of the
biggest channels for documentaries on
money power and crime so if you enjoyed
this video we make multiple videos just
like this one every single week for free
so click that subscribe button below and
if you want longer documentaries that
are too controversial to be posted
publicly click that join button below
there's also a refund policy so if you
join and you don't think it's worth it i
will refrain you the money just email me
about it that is gonna wrap it up thank
you so much for watching stay dangerous
out there and i will see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
you